hi I'm Eric Voss and Black Panther it's
one of the most entertaining richly
designed must-watch Marvel movies ever
kind of felt like Martin Freeman in this
movie oh yeah I'm just gonna enjoy this
but if Yuri watch black panther closely
there are a ton of subtle interesting
choices by director Ryan Coogler and his
whole creative team that make this film
so great cultural influences a look at
the spell miscible connections to the
other films in the Marvel world so join
me as I uncover all of these details and
Easter eggs whatever you want to call
them and of course spoiler warning if
you haven't seen Black Panther yet
unless you know you'd prefer to watch a
movie with a nerd talking you through it
and if so what's wrong with you let's
get started okay so this movie begins
with this interesting prologue taking
the form of a story told from father to
son showing us the history of Wakanda
and its people while the outside world
ascends into war and slavery and right
away we get a taste of this film
spectacular production design notice how
this history is depicted with grains of
darks and Hannah beech lured the
production designer said she wanted to
think about how an African nation might
have evolved with vibranium enriched
soil and that this sand would be
something that links the modern-day
wakandans to their ancestors thousands
of years ago we actually see this
granular vibranium show up again a few
scenes later when T'Challa uses it to
display the truck convoy containing
Nakia in the jungle below this prologue
firmly establishes Black Panther with
its own distinct voice and identity but
also in a way it does echo past Marvel
movies the first two Thor movies
remember open with similar narrative
prologues from a hidden worlds
patriarchy in that case Odin to catch us
up on the whole origins you know that it
a super interesting one that we all
think about all the time like frost
giants and whatnot then we move on from
this prologue to 1992 Oakland California
which we learned through this
interesting title text on the screen it
translates from the wakandan language
into English and I like how it
translates this movie's role as
translating this new Wakanda nation in
society from something foreign to us
to something we understand the design
team created a whole new volcon Dhin
alphabet and like most design elements
of this movie they rooted it in ancient
African traditions in this case these
letters resemble the characters of insa
bidding and ancient cuneiform from
Nigeria by the way the spoken wakandan
language
is polska which is a dialect known for
the clicks that I'm probably kidding
that all correct it's based in South
Africa figures like Nelson Mandela
spoken also the choice to set the splash
back scene in Auckland is no coincidence
either Auckland is director Ryan Coogler
hometown it was a setting for his
directorial debut Fruitvale station and
it has its own historical significance
as the birthplace of the Black Panther
Party in the 60s actually if you look
closely inside in Joe Cool's apartment
there are posters for early 90s rap
groups like NWA and Public Enemy both of
whom adopted many of the Black Panther
party's messages individually risks and
on this TV screen is news footage
showing the Rodney King riots now I'll
talk more about how these political and
cultural influences work into the
character dynamics later on but few more
interesting details I want to point out
here the actor who plays the younger
version of tataka is a Towanda Connie
the real-life son of John Connie who
plays the older tataka
meanwhile the young version of Zuri is
played by Denzel Whitaker who isn't
related to Forest Whitaker but did work
with them in the movie the Great
Debaters his character describes the
Dermalogica guards outside as Grace
Jones looking ticks Grace Jones was a
Jamaican singer and actress with a
similar hook guys adore logic moving on
to the modern day with two chawla
rescuing Nakia in the African jungle
here we meet a Koi a Danai gurira from
The Walking Dead Sea's the general of
the Durham illogic notice the tattoos on
her bald head the makeup team designed
those to resemble the shape of a fighter
pilots helmet but in addition to this
militaristic look they also gave her eye
makeup to look more feline to show her
devotion to Black Panther so later when
duty calls ultimately her heart goes
with the Panther as the charlet drops
out of the ship we also see the Komodo
beads in action now these are from the
recent black panther comics by
tightening sea coats and Brian Steele
frees super he's designed them as a
multi-purpose technology used for like
communication and health and weaponry
with the look that routes them in
traditional African jewelry this
particular comic series was hugely
influential for this screen adaptation
of Black Panther and I'll talk more
about that in a bit but first he may
have also been wondering what exactly
Nakia was doing down there like Panther
is rescuing her but she's actually on a
rescue mission of her own saving these
young women as well as a young male
soldier I think this is meant to reflect
the current crisis in western Africa
where the terrorist group Boko Haram
kidnapped hundreds of Nigerian
schoolgirls through
is also known for kidnapping young boys
and brainwashing them into child
soldiers
so this mission establishes Nakia as
more globally conscious than her
wakandan people seeking to use her
resources to intervene in international
crises now we will see how this
philosophy puts her in a way on the
similar side of the spectrum as kill
monger against two challahs isolationist
mindset and how those two will be
responsible for moving to chalo to more
of a middle ground moving on these three
return to what Conda hidden in plain
sight but what looks like a camouflage
dome this reminds me a lot of the way
the island of famous Kira was masked and
Wonder Woman cannot saying either rip
top the other it's just said there's
this interesting parallel for these two
game-changing heroes from hidden utopias
now the city is also taking design
influences from that recent black
panther comic that I mentioned and what
made that series distinctive was the way
Tana hasy coats embraced a concept
called afrofuturism after a futurism is
a concept in philosophy art and
literature that examines racial themes
through the lens of science fiction an
idealized advanced future that still
embraces elements of present-day culture
so while the city contains massive
futuristic skyscrapers which by the way
the design team said that they borrowed
from Blade Runner if you look closely at
the tops of those skyscrapers there are
Rhonda bells the traditional African Hut
roofs also down the street level in
addition to the magnetized levitation
elevated train that zips through the
city there's a slower trolley that rolls
around which may have been inspired by
the Bay Area trolleys that Ryan Coogler
grew up with the overall effectiveness
is a futuristic sci-fi world that feels
like it could have plausibly evolved
from an undisturbed African culture over
thousands of years something alive and
lived in and practical also can we make
this place a part of Disneyland already
because I want to go to there this
afro-futurist approach was also snuck
into the design of the jet that they're
flying in you look closely when the
bottom of this jet was made to look like
an African tribal mask with the engines
as eyeholes that gives an even deeper
meaning to the looks at those boys in
Oakland gave the jettison hovered over
them
T'Challa greets his mother Queen Ramona
played by Angela Bassett and his sister
Cherie
played by Leticia Wright and both of
these characters have some very
interesting design details notice our
Amanda wears a traditional cylindrical
Zulu hat in a white circular shoulder
mantle veteran costume designer Ruth
Carter 3d printed all these wanting the
hats of
like an impressive crown from every
angle north east south and west
considering several tribes would be seen
heard from all sides and she wanted the
mantle to look like a Setting Sun behind
her to reflect the state of mourning of
the Sun setting on her marriage
meanwhile Carter pointed out Jerry's
interesting braids as a key reflection
of her character notice how in every
scene shuri's braids take a new shape
and she wears a new wardrobe she
actually is the most costume changes of
any character in this movie this is all
to show that she's a trendsetter in a
fashion-forward Princess of Wakanda
checking in on London where we meet
Michael B Jordan as kill monger my
favorite character in this movie perhaps
the best villain we've seen so far in
the MCU his exchange with the museum
curator establishes his philosophy as a
villain he isn't just motivated by
revenge or power he sees it as his
mission to correct the mass oppression
of his race the pillaging of their
natural resources exploiting his
ancestors themselves as resources in the
slave trade and as his father points out
in the later flashback the ongoing
oppression into the modern day and while
in janaka's aims to militarize his race
with Wakanda technology to violently
overthrow society might be too extreme
his anger is totally justified he's not
crazy or wrong he's just too extreme and
by establishing the villain with this
philosophy Ryan Coogler links this
dynamic between in judoka and T'Challa
with the debate at the heart of the
civil rights movement on one side
followers of Martin Luther King jr.
preached civil unrest and peaceful
protests symbolic gestures meanwhile
followers of Malcolm X believed in
action in fighting back against an
oppressive regime even violently if
necessary and approached in Jeddah has
definitely embraced these themes are
explored deeply in the films of Spike
Lee in his Malcolm X biopic and do the
right thing which by the way Ruth Carter
designed the costumes for this debate
actually goes back to the early days of
the civil rights movement to scholars
like W EB Du Bois and Booker T
Washington who had opposing views on the
means of African American advancement
shout-out to dr. Dan slur on Twitter for
that the takeaway of all this is Ryan
Coogler was able to use history to make
the fight between these superhero and
supervillain thematically important they
aren't just two men fighting over a
throne they're forces fighting over an
ideal and it's surprising how the movie
answers that question it's just one of
the many reasons Black Panther is
resonating with Audie
so strongly back in Wakanda to chala
ascends to the throne through this
ritual ad warrior Falls now notice how
the five wakandan tribes wear different
wardrobes hairstyles and accessories now
these all correspond to real-life
African cultures Ryan Coogler spent a
month in Africa writing the script for
black panther and doing a ton of
research the production designer
actually created a 500 page book hundun
bible explaining the whole design and
cultural influences of the world of what
conduct going through these tribes
there's the border tribe headed by
daniel kahlúa as Maccabi this tribe
wears a lot of blue and they use wood
they're inspired by the people of
Lesotho who wear basil--oh blankets this
tribe features body scarification
inspired by the mercy & Gumi tribes of
Ethiopia
then there's the River tribe of which
Nakia is a member they were green with
shells as part of their patterns their
leader is played by Isaac to bankroll a
who wears a large lip dist piercing lip
plating is another detail pulled from
the mercy of the Ethiopian then there's
the merchant tribe they were white
inspired by Nigerian cultures the mining
tribe wears red inspired by the Himba
tribe of namibia famous for treating
their hair with red clay which you can
see in their leaders braids and then
there's the main Black Panther tribe
they wear black and purple colors
derived from the black vibranium colors
and the purple colored heart shaped
herbed that the sources of this tribes
strength traditional body scarification
also inspired the glowing inner lip
tattoo that wakandans have as well as
kill mongers self-applied scars they
were pulled from the Surma tribe of
ethiopia now the tribe outside these
five is the mountain tribe that Jabari
led bite in Baku he's played by Winston
Duke now in the comics mbaku is known as
man ape they changed it to avoid any
racial connotation but they kept is
guerrilla iconography with this gorilla
skull mask now the production designers
said that she wanted this warrior falls
location on real-life settings like
glide Canyon where the rocks are shelled
in a way to block you in creating a
natural cage match for warriors to have
nowhere to go moving on T'Challa retakes
the heart-shaped herb fluid from Zuri
and transcends into the ancestral plane
which could be based on to Julia from
the Black Panther comics it's a realm
where the living can commune with the
dead here he communes with his past
ancestors in the form of these Panther
spirits as well as his father to Chaka
communing with his ancestors as spirit
guides is actually something black
panther doesn't do in the comics okay
let's jump ahead to this scene with two
chala and Sheree in her lab the teacher
right is so great in this movie she
seems to be embracing cue from the
double-oh-seven movies and she just has
some of the best jokes in the movie like
when she looks down two brothers royal
sandals and screams what are those then
she gets to table a new pair of boots
that are fully automated like the old
American movie their dad used to watch
she's referencing Marty McFly's
self-lacing shoes and Back to the Future
Part two and then later on Cherie makes
another movie reference to Ross who asks
is this what Conda and she jokes no it's
Kansas referencing that obscure movie
that I think was called well it's what
The Wiz was based on I don't know I've
never heard of this now one of the suit
designs she shows T'Challa has a gold
trim similar to the design her father
wore in the opening scene this could be
a nod to the gold trim black panther
suit from the comics in the 90s the new
suit sure he gives him with the shock
absorbing kinetic energy tech has some
will Condon runes on it this could be a
reference to the run in the comics when
Black Panther moves away from vibranium
technology instead using magic as the
source of his powers really what I love
most about this lab is the overall
design of the layout it's located inside
the vibranium mine of Mount mashenka
which is named after the first what kind
of king that we saw in the prologue the
central walkway the lab is shaped like a
spiral almost like a giant drill that's
drilling into this mountain actually I
should point out that all of the design
of the wakandan palace is based on
circular shapes the throne the Jets the
overall architecture of the floor layout
the designers did this to set what kind
of part for the mountain tribe whose
architecture features more sharp angles
the idea being that Wakanda is a more
community-based union of tribes whereas
the mountain tribe diverges on their own
angular tangent okay moving on to Busan
South Korea now what's the man the
colour of the characters wardrobes
carries a lot of symbolic weight here
Nakia to chala and Ikoyi are wearing
green black and red respectively in a
breakdown of the scene that he did for
Vanity Fair Ryan Coogler said that no
other characters wear red or green in
the scene he wanted these three to stand
out because red black and green are the
colors of the pan-african flag Martin
Freeman's
CIA agent Everett Ross returns here at
the same table as
Stanly making a cameo as a gambler who
takes two challahs ships for safety
McCoy a has to wear a wig disguise to
blend in which frustrates her because
the Dorma lodges shaved heads is a point
of pride for them but notice how later
when fighting she pulls off the wig and
tosses it in a dudes face according to
Kugler this is an example of
traditionalism versus innovation in this
scene with female characters using their
femininity as a weapon
so while Akoya takes out these guys with
traditional spear movements the wig
becomes a weapon too similarly down
below notice how Nakia pulls off or
he'll and pizza guy with it now the
second half of this casino fight is shot
in one awesome long extended take this
is actually a director trademark of ryan
coogler in the movie Creed he shot an
entire boxing match in one four and a
half minute long take and this is super
effective because it brings us into the
action having us experience all of this
in real time just like the characters
are and during this you can hear this
interesting Yip vocals doing a you like
a choo choo choo this is the music of
door cue a group of women singers from
Senegal and at the end of this tracking
shot ulysses klaw punctuate sit by using
his arm cannon to blow up the cashbox
kind of like the confetti to celebrate
the end of this shot in the comics Klaw
actually has a similar sonic arm cannon
that fires these sonic blasts he also at
one point gets sucked into a machine and
turned into a form made of entirely
sound energy yeah I'm glad I didn't go
too far with that the action spills
outside leading to this great car chase
through the streets of Busan it's
interesting how elaborate series mapping
technology is not only could she control
the Lexus remotely back in the lab the
lab holo projects the car's interior and
the surrounding city street as it passes
by all into review kind of like a 3d
Google Streetview
now in the scene it just seems like some
fun but probably unnecessary superhero
movie tech but like everything in this
movie everything is reused later on all
this is put in place to set up Ross
needing to use this technology later to
take down the outgoing weapon cargo
ships later when Janaka breaks claw out
of captivity he wears that horn
tribal mask that he stole from the
museum earlier this mask could be a nod
to the one kill monger wears while
fighting T'Challa and Reginald Hudlin
black panther comic and when joe dhaka
toss
a grenade into the room like Panther
jumps on it to block the explosion now
this could be another MCU nod of course
this is the same act of heroism that
Steve Rogers did in Captain America the
First Avenger when they bring the
injured Ross back to Wakanda sure he
calls him another broken white boy for
us to fix this is a subtle reference to
Bucky Barnes she's setting up the winter
soldiers cameo in the post-credits scene
next when T'Challa confronts Suri in the
garden about Angelica's ring we learned
the truth about the opening scene in the
memory and Jobu rants about leaders
being assassinated communities being
overly drugged and incarcerated he's
referring to the assassinations as civil
rights leaders like Martin Luther King
jr. and Malcolm X Medgar Evers and
unfortunately several others he also
alludes to the mass incarceration of
African Americans in the u.s. explored
in super depth by Ava Duvernay and her
documentary xiii which you really need
to watch now Zuri was described by the
filmmakers as an obi-wan Kenobi figure
during press junkets and now having
watched the movie it's interesting to
see the parallels
both men are mystic elder figures who
hide the truth from the heroes about
their father's dark pasts also both
elders sacrificed themselves leading
each hero to let out a boyish oh okay
moving on to in jeta's arrival to the
Wakanda throne room now at this point
Michael B Jordan has completely altered
the rhythm of this movie whereas
everyone else speaks in respectful royal
tones his language is more casual he
greets Queen worm onda by saying hey
auntie I think the closest parallel to
the way of villain works in a superhero
movie is Heath Ledger's the Joker in the
Dark Knight like the Joker in judoka
takes over every scene that he's in he
wins over people with actual results
instead of just words and he burns this
world's most precious commodity just to
make a statement most importantly he
drives forward with the philosophy
that's better defined than the hero's is
and part of us kind of wants to see him
succeed even though we know that that
would be terrible
like yes it's wrong for injured akka to
try to weaponize millions of people
worldwide with superior technology to
enact some sort of global reverse
oppression but that extremists position
ultimately changes to Chawla who is
moved to step away from his isolationist
ancestors toward a more open door policy
just one that's more peaceful and
practical than in two decades by the way
that's something that the Joker does too
in the Dark Knight
Joker never really changes as a
character but his extreme anarchist
philosophy teaches Batman that
villainous pariahs are more effective at
mobilizing society to take their
security into their own hands which is
why Batman takes on the role of pariah
at the end of that movie yeah yeah I
know I'm getting sidetracked here so
let's quickly compare black plant they
do another thing that I love Daniel ouya
actually described this story as
Marvel's Game of Thrones and yeah you
can see how this royal drama echoes the
inner family rivalries and battles for
Thrones in that show when in Judah
challenges to chala back at warrior
falls he says the line every breath you
take his mercy from me which is a direct
quote from a black panther versus Namor
moment in the comics it also ends with
in Judah tossing him off the waterfall
which is another thing that he does in
the comics when Angelica drinks the
heart-shaped herb and enters the
ancestral plane he returns to the memory
of losing his father that's interesting
how we get this shot of him cradling his
father crying and it's staged very
similarly to two challahs memory of
cradling his father's body
I think this parallel is meant to make
us empathize with the villain as much as
we do the hero to force ourselves to
really think about which of their
philosophies is the right one now if you
look closely during this memory and Joe
boos diary features this map of Wakanda
and these coordinates now this could be
left behind for his young son to find
and reach the homeland someday or maybe
these are the ones that he gave to
Claude to break in and steal the
vibranium
anyway if you entered these coordinates
into Google Earth they actually take you
to the heart of Africa the northeastern
corner of the Democratic Republic of
Congo near the Ugandan border actually
this is almost exactly where on the map
that Easter Egg appeared an Iron Man -
hinting at shields awareness of Wakanda
back then when injured akka returns to
the throne room
koogler frames it with this interesting
upside down shot now this disorientation
is meant to evoke ow upside down this
world of Wakanda has become with this
usurper now on the throne as in Judah
announces his plans he says the words
The Sun will never set on the empire
Wakanda now this is a historical
reference to the phrase the empire on
which the Sun never sets
originally referring to the Spanish
Empire in the 1500s which spans several
hemispheres so that the Sun was always
up on some part of it later on the
phrase is used to describe the empires
of the United Kingdom the US and Japan
the ex royal family and Ross retreat to
the mountains to seek the help of mbaku
who
delivers this great big threat to Ross
I'll feed you to my children and just
get him we're all vegetarians now this
could be an odd tootin baku 'he's back
story in the comics his tribe eats two
flesh and bathes in the blood of the
white gorilla but yeah Winston Dukes
version is way more relatable and way
more fun
and after they revived T'Challa all the
key players confront each other in this
final battle now I hate to draw too many
parallels between this movie and the
Lion King because guys not all Africa
stories are the same but yeah this Black
Panther epic returned from the dead to
challenge a usurper moments definitely
evokes Simba's return to face scar but
really let's be honest they're both
referencing Shakespeare's Hamlet in
which Hamlet thought to be killed
returns from the dead sort of two phases
uncle and usurper Cuates in Janaka shows
his own vibranium armor which was
referred to as the golden jaguar suit
it's interesting how this gold trim is
the exact necklace two challahs got that
earlier saying the goal was to not be
noticed but and Xhaka embraces the idea
of being noticed because that's his
whole philosophy he doesn't want to live
in secret he wants to proudly show off
his superiority that idea was also
reflected in the design of the mask
whereas two challahs mask has no mouth
evoking his silence and stoic Ness in
jeddah cos mask features an open roaring
mouth with gnashing teeth implying his
character's brashness during this battle
we see the Warriors of the border tribe
assemble their cloaks into a shield wall
this is reminiscent of the ancient Roman
soldier formation called a phalanx where
they assembled their shields into a wall
to close in on enemies and block arrow
fire we also see Black Panther take down
one of the border tribes rhinos which is
an image from the comics once T'Challa
defeats Indy Jocko on the train platform
he brings him out to see the sunset we
actually saw the Chawla exercise this
kind of mercy at the end of the Captain
America Civil War with Baron Zemo
but this also closes out two parts of in
judokas arc for one it allows him to
finally see the wakandans sunset that
his father promised him but it also
calls back his promise that the Sun
would never set on the Empire will
conduct here the Sun is indeed setting
on Wakanda and in judokas Empire was
never meant to be his final words are so
powerful bury me in the ocean with my
ancestors that jump from the ships they
knew that death was better than bondage
in a few short words engine taka links
the history of the African slave trade
with the mass incarceration of America
today he's
minding T'Challa that although he lost
his battle those crimes of humanity have
never truly been resolved and you could
argue that that argument ultimately wins
the war and the lessons he learns from
in Judea and Nakia eventually lead him
back to the starting place of in judokas
journey and this movie Auckland but now
we see that T'Challa has started to make
improvements the old bottom doubt milk
crate has been replaced by a new hoop
and he explains to Shuri that the old
project will be turned into an Outreach
Center ryan coogler suggesting that the
answer isn't violence or revenge
the answer is redirecting our energies
back into the communities to bring them
up with education and sharing of
resources the symmetry of this closing
image was so important to Kugler that he
actually moved the movie's original
ending two challahs powerful speech to
the UN to the mid-credits scene instead
he leaves us with this this young boy
who sees two challahs wakandan ship and
marvels at him by the way this actors
Alex Hibbert he played the young version
of Charonne in moonlight here he
represents the younger generation of
youths who now have a hero to look up to
and a positive example of what makes the
best superheroes heroic a question I
have for you guys for a Black Panther
sequel who would you rather it follow
T'Challa
or another character like Sheree or in
Baku comment and tell me your thoughts
down below tweet me directly Eddie a vas
and follow new rockstars on Twitter at
new rock stars or updates on our videos
and of course subscribe the new rock
stars for more black panther analysis
there's really so much to talk about
with this movie keep an eye out for more
videos that we're gonna do about the
music of the movie as well as our
thoughts on that mystery of where the
final infinity stone is and if you
really like us someone to help us grow
you can contribute to this channel on
patreon big thanks to all of our donors
especially Kenny Smith thanks for
watching guys bye